Trascrizione: Beatrice Penna
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Di solito, i riflettori sono così forti
in prigione, se ti devono interrogare.
Stasera, cercherò di staccarmi
da questa idea.
Nella vita ci sono dei momenti "segnanti",
in cui ti rendi conto
che a seconda delle scelte che tu farai,
la tua vita potrebbe
cambiare radicalmente.
Io li chiamo "i momenti
del brivido alla colonna".
E questo accadde anche a me:
Nel 2003, inaspettatamente,
fui contattata con una proposta
che negli anni ho sempre definito
come una proposta indecente.
Mi venne chiesto di aprire
una cooperativa di catering
all’interno di un carcere,
insieme a detenuti in quel momento
assegnati al settore della ristorazione.
Il senso del darli proprio a me c’era:
Per dieci anni avevo gestito
un catering molto esclusivo:
coccolavo la buona borghesia.
E mi venne fatta questa proposta,
su cui io riflettei, inizialmente,
perché del carcere non sapevo nulla.
Avevo una grossa esperienza,
sicuramente, nell’ambito del sociale -
perché per 22 anni avevo fatto
l’educatrice di scuola materna
nelle periferie della città di Milano,
nei quartieri più disagiati,
con situazioni familiari molto faticose;
avevo persino fatto due anni
di servizio civile in Uganda.
Ma del carcere proprio no,
non ne sapevo nulla.
Vorrei capire, insieme a voi,
che cos’è il carcere.
Il carcere questo sconosciuto,
noi potremmo dire.
Il carcere ha una certezza, però:
il carcere è il luogo
dove finiscono le persone
che hanno trasgredito le regole.
A prescindere dal motivo,
questo punto accomuna tutti i detenuti.
È il luogo, quindi,
per chi non ha rispettato le regole.
Ma quando tu entri,
perché ti viene comminata la pena,
e inizi il tuo percorso,
io definisco questo luogo “un non luogo”.
Il carcere diventa un non luogo
perché una volta dentro
perdi ogni diritto a essere
creduto e ascoltato.
E questo già non è poco.
È il momento in cui perdi
tutte le tue amicizie abituali;
e tu ti trovi, improvvisamente,
a condividere il quotidiano
con "vicini di casa"
che non ti saresti mai immaginato,
neppure per un momento, di avvicinare.
È il non-luogo del non-tempo.
Tutte le prigioni hanno lunghi corridoi
che sono pieni di orologi alle pareti,
ma sono tutti fermi.
In realtà, contare gli anni che passano
con i minuti, e i secondi,
è davvero faticoso.
Probabilmente, è quasi terapeutico
che questi orologi non funzionino.
È il luogo dove perdi la possibilità
di ogni minima scelta.
E da quel momento,
inizia la tua involuzione.
Quando arrivi alla fine della pena,
e potrai uscire fuori,
sarai una persona totalmente disinserita
dalla società esterna.
E non solo:
è il luogo delle afflizioni,
grandi e piccole che siano.
Ogni afflizione contribuirà,
sempre di più,
a farti uscire come una persona
fortemente arrabbiata.
Sarai così arrabbiato
da sentirti tu la vittima;
e dimenticherai, a quel punto,
di aver generato tu delle vittime,
perché chi commette un reato
comunque genera delle vittime.
E il tuo presunto "reinserimento"
sarà assolutamente inesistente.
Questo è un paradosso,
soprattutto se pensiamo a cosa recita
la nostra Costituzione.
L’articolo 27 della
Costituzione Italiana dice:
"Le pene non possono consistere
in trattamenti contrari
al senso di umanità
e devono tendere alla
rieducazione del condannato"
Alla luce di questo,
noi dobbiamo pensare
se un altro carcere è possibile.
Il carcere di Bollate,
che è nato tra la fine degli anni 90
e i primi del 2000,
è un istituto penitenziario
che all’epoca venne definito
"a trattamento avanzato".
Questo perché ha provato ad attuare
tutti quei meccanismi
già previsti sia dalla Costituzione,
che dall’ordinamento penitenziario,
per un vero tentativo
di recupero delle persone.
Non è stata una rivoluzione:
direi che è un’ovvietà.
Ma contemporaneamente, è stata
una Rivoluzione Copernicana.
In questo percorso,
penso che legittimamente mi chiedereste
cosa c’entra la cucina.
La cucina è una bella storia.
Io amo definirla una forma
di tossicodipendenza, ve lo garantisco:
è una malattia che ti pervade totalmente.
La mia cucina dell’ultimo minuto è:
apro il frigo e faccio,
per la gioia di mio marito,
così compenso l’esser sempre in prigione.
Questa passione ha un senso profondo.
Occuparsi di cibo vuol dire
risvegliare tutti i nostri sensi:
profumi, odori, sapori, colori.
Non da ultimo, il dono più grande
è quello di accogliere l’altro, l’ospite,
che per l’uomo è una delle funzioni
più alte, più importanti.
Il legame con chi è privato della libertà
acquisisce allora un senso fortissimo.
Mettere a disposizione dei detenuti,
nella forma del lavoro,
la possibilità di creare, inventare,
preparare piatti nuovi,
è iniziare a saltare oltre il muro.
Non dimentichiamo che questo muro
è l’unica cosa che queste persone
hanno visto per dieci anni.
Dobbiamo quindi cominciare
a scavalcarlo coi progetti, con le idee,
e prepararli per questo.
Così io avviai, come vi ho detto prima,
la proposta indecente:
avviai questa cooperativa
con un gruppo di detenuti.
Ma posi anch’io delle condizioni,
due in particolare.
La prima: volevo fare un anno di prova.
Volevo avere una certezza,
che tutto ciò si potesse
trasformare in un vero lavoro.
La dignità delle persone,
quindi un lavoro retribuito
e una professionalità.
La seconda fu proprio una provocazione,
lo capirete se conoscete un minimo
le regole che blindano il carcere.
Dissi: vorrei che il nostro non sia
il "catering della misericordia",
porterò il bon ton in galera.
Questo fu l’aspetto dirompente,
che fece poi la differenza.
Con la complicità
dei magistrati di sorveglianza,
perché ogni detenuto può uscire
con la misura alternativa
in applicazione delle regole
e delle leggi previste,
con la complicità
dei magistrati di sorveglianza,
degli educatori, della Polizia
Penitenziaria stessa
che per la prima volta
vedeva dei detenuti uscire
ad allestire banchetti molto importanti.
Cominciammo così,
e in un paio d’anni consolidammo
una clientela decisamente affezionata
che ci fece capire che si poteva fare.
Ripetevamo sempre: noi ci proviamo.
Uscire con dei camerieri detenuti
che indossavano la livrea bianca,
quella del vecchio cameriere
di casa coi bottoni oro,
fu lo stratagemma che mi aiutò a coprire
i trucidi tatuaggi che molti avevano.
(Risate)
Poi, la scuola del bon ton
fu straordinaria,
perché ribalta l’immaginario
del detenuto brutto e cattivo.
Tutto ciò ci spinse ad andare avanti.
La cosa fondamentale
era una vera professione,
una vera professionalità.
I detenuti vennero assunti:
noi siamo la cooperativa sociale
"Abc - La sapienza in tavola".
Cominciarono a raccogliere
tutta una serie di consensi.
Ma il problema più grosso
non è solo dare un posto di lavoro
alle persone all’interno dell’istituto.
Il problema più grosso è la credibilità.
Io ho imparato
che la magistratura, quasi sempre,
un fine pena lo da.
Chi da il "Fine pena mai"
siamo noi, quelli oltre il muro.
E ho anche capito perché questo avviene.
Ho capito che l’essere umano
ha paura di ciò che non conosce.
Allora, noi dobbiamo fare
un’operazione al contrario.
La realtà ribaltata l’ho imparata
dal carcere, dai detenuti stessi.
Società, tu non sai
cos’è il carcere, e chi c’è dentro;
ora te lo faccio vedere io.
E invece di uscire noi,
che comunque continuiamo a uscire
anche facendo i catering,
avendo confermato un importante
calo della recidiva -
a Bollate scende sotto al 17%,
sul territorio nazionale è del 70%.
Forti di questo abbiamo lanciato
una provocazione,
sapevo essere una provocazione.
Aprire un ristorante
nell’Istituto di Bollate,
aperto al pubblico e gestito dai detenuti.
Ed ecco, nel 2015, "InGalera",
nasce il primo ristorante al mondo
aperto al pubblico e gestito da detenuti.
Noi ci proviamo.
Io vorrei sottolineare
che ho appena scoperto un nuovo termine,
coniato da un genio secondo me,
che si chiama "umbizione".
È la crasi tra umiltà e ambizione.
Questa è la nostra ricchezza,
noi ci proviamo.
Andiamo avanti con entusiasmo e fiducia,
perché quasi 20 anni di storia
ci supportano e ci aiutano molto.
Io dal carcere ho imparato molto,
così come dai detenuti stessi.
Una cosa, secondo me importantissima,
che ho imparato
è il senso della simmetria del corpo.
Noi abbiamo due gambe, e io ho imparato
che su una gamba porto
il percorso di speranza,
e accompagno queste persone a farlo:
I nostri detenuti hanno
molti anni da scontare,
quindi è un percorso,
anche, parecchio lungo.
Su questa gamba c'è la loro speranza,
e il guardare avanti.
Sull’altra gamba, e ho imparato
quanto sia fondamentale,
si porta la sofferenza delle vittime
che ogni persona in carcere ha generato,
indipendentemente dal reato.
Questo equilibrio mi ricorda
che il dolore che hanno provocato,
e che comunque li segnerà a vita,
questo dolore non annulla la speranza,
che deve continuare ad esserci,
ad andare avanti
perché è solo nel nostro interesse
riavere queste persone molto meglio
di quando erano entrate.
Vorrei ora regalarvi
alcune frasi di lessico carcerario,
mi sembrano importanti perché sono certa
che voi non le conoscete.
Una di queste è "montare le biciclette":
significa inventare pettegolezzi
per mettere in cattiva luce qualcuno.
Non bisogna montare biciclette,
ricordiamocelo anche fuori.
L’altra frase l’ho spesso
rivendicata io stessa:
guardate che io "me la canto".
Non era una minaccia, era un’esternazione
per chiarire che tutto il nostro percorso
agiva nel pieno del rispetto delle regole.
Dico sempre che io,
e le persone che lavorano con me
abbiamo imparato che si possono
scoprire nuovi mondi
in due modi:
o da pionieri, o da pirati.
Noi, con orgoglio, abbiamo
sempre scelto il primo modo.
Vi lascio, poi,
alcuni piccoli stratagemmi.
Per chi entra al ristorante a mangiare,
meglio non dire alla fine
"Sono in ritardo, devo scappare".
Non si può. (Risate)
Oppure, se parlate
al telefono con qualcuno,
non potete dire "scusa un secondino":
È un termine obsoleto:
ora si chiama poliziotto penitenziario.
E poi la mia vera gioia,
e questa è davvero una rivoluzione:
per la prima volta al mondo,
quando entrate nel Ristorante "In Galera",
io posso dirvi: "Benvenuti in galera".
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)